hi Devon Carmichael welcome to the first
edition of our Twitter $10,000 challenge
update this all started by friend of
mine who's a local entrepreneur here in
Toronto named Shawn Moffitt and this is
his Twitter profile he's the Shawn
Moffitt on Twitter he says his hearts in
New York City but he's based in Toronto
I don't know about that sean i think i
think tron is a pretty good place to
live anyway I met with Sean a little bit
ago and we had coffee and he's an expert
in helping entrepreneurs make sales
through Twitter and I said that's great
Sean you know a lot of people are trying
to figure out how they can monetize
Twitter you know they see people
updating their statuses and talking
about their cats and what they for lunch
and trying to figure out how they can
make money from this and so I said how
about this as a challenge you help me
get ten thousand dollars in new business
through Twitter alone and he said he's
up for the challenge and so with these
videos what I'm going to try to do is
update you through the process of how
we're doing if we've made some money
from it and kind of give you a
step-by-step process of what we're doing
and see if it works or not so Shan Shan
Zhou asked reputation is on the line
here and hopefully it works and so this
is a first update so Sean strategy
basically the start with is connecting
with your potential clients on Twitter
go and find you know who your ideal
prospects are see if they have an
account and start connecting with them
you know look at what they're tweeting
respond to it retweet get involved in
the conversation this is a a step one to
get on their radar screen and so i'm
going to show you what i did i started
using tools with HootSuite and i'll give
you a quick example of what I did if I
load up my where's my HootSuite mr.
these tweets I was trying to find a
quick way to be able to follow all the
people who I was interested in now the
challenge that i found was if you look
use a tool like HootSuite some people
tweet a lot and some people don't tweet
at all and i wanted to find a way to
once a week being touch with all the
people who were on my ideal prospects
list so I made a list I've got maybe
almost a hundred people on that list and
these are companies and key influencers
who target either my market or who are
my potential customers that I want to
reach out to and build relationships
with again only through Twitter that's
that's the goal it's got to be
through Twitter and so HootSuite is
great at building lists i have a list of
my sent tweets my family bloggers that i
follow mentions in some business some of
my clients i'm currently working with
this is an example here where telus
business might tweet a lot and
quickbooks may not tweet as much and so
you can leave you can often get your
twitter feed bombarded with some of the
people who write a lot and you miss out
on some of the other ones who don't so I
found my first challenge was building a
tool to be able to quickly stay in touch
with all of these people and so my goal
initially starting up was to once a week
be in touch with every person on my list
by either either retweeting something
they wrote or by commenting on one of
their tweets so I can hopefully stay top
of mind when they have an issue that
they need some help with they will reach
out to me so what I did was I had my
programmer build a custom tool I started
trying to do it myself but I'm not
strong enough with the twitter api to
build it and what i did here was on my
daily tasks i built a list of lists for
each day so this is Monday up into
Sunday and every day I basically go
through and see the tweets that are on
that page so today is Wednesday so let
me load up the Wednesday list and see
what I have to go through and so here
are some of the people who target either
my market or who are my potential
customers so while ebooks crowd spring
wells fargo datacom D&B credibility
verizon small business and basically it
shows the top 10 most recent tweets that
they put out and there's links to them
and basically what i do every day now is
i spend a couple minutes in the morning
while I'm eating my lentils for
breakfast to go through and see how i
can add value or contribute to the
conversation for each of these key
points so a look at this i'll see what
the most recent one is i'll check out
the links see if i have something to say
about it either congratulate them on the
good post or you know contribute some
thoughts that i may have or share a link
or retweet it to my audience and ideas
basically get on there get on their good
side make sure they know me and
hopefully some business opportunities
can come from that so that was my first
task that Sean gave me he was saying
basically go find the list make a list
of your ideal prospect
and and find a way to stay in touch with
them on a regular basis so I'm happy
with my tool now and I'm following up
with them and that's basically all
that's happened in my first you know
quick update here just two guys let you
guys know what we're doing I find that
maybe one in three two one in five
people companies will write back so if I
you know this is done in bradstreet or
verizon small business if i see a post
that I like and I comment on it's a
great post or give my two cents on it I
find that right now about one in three
two one in five are writing back to me
either just saying thank you or a happy
face or something just acknowledging it
I found that some of them start to
follow me back you know we haven't had
any any business happen yet so that
ten-thousand-dollar challenge is still
out there but this is just the first
quick update I'm hopefully meeting with
Sean either for some sushi dinner or
coffee later this week early next week
and we'll discuss strategy and and as I
figure out what my next steps are with
him I will update you guys and again the
goals to get ten thousand dollars in new
business only through twitter using sean
strategies and we're kind of kind of
guide you through it step by step was it
go along the way so that's it for my
update for today if you guys liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
and makes me know you are following this
project they want to learn more and if
you have a question about what we're
doing a question for me or question for
Sean feel free to leave in the comments
section below we always read those and
will try to respond to everybody so
thank you stay tuned for the next video
and hopeful in for a good ride